what made you
start doing hats i fell in love with a
little girl she looked great in the
house and i want to adorn her
whatever happened with the girl lost the
girl but gained the trade
i'm going for that if i go by two chains
two chains
i'm over the top sometimes seriously and
right now we're going to check out the
most expensive this [ __ ]
it's definitely crazy yo we back it's
two chains
most expensive is [ __ ] and right now
we're going to check out work and work
the infamous panama hat very interesting
hello hello hello mr orlando how you
doing
nice to meet you man yeah you're the
famous hat maker i hear a lot about you
man what do you hear they got to do with
swaggy got to do with orlando man that's
what they tell me
what you got going on i got panamas i
wear hats almost every day and i'm just
thinking how i can probably inject this
into my swag into my rap swag
the first thing i would do is i'd
measure you up right
so come around the back
over your occipital bone obviously it's
my simple two bone
when i come side to side you divide that
by pi and that's your head size
you learned this trying to get you
something i see men scale mountains
together
i've done some crazy things myself man
after i've sculpted blocks
i take a raw body this is a panel they
work best with water
do you need any kind of specific water
you just i use distilled water because
really
okay guys i used to still water that's a
good question and then i have a good
question
and then you just moisten it with your
hands with that oh
throw some names around some people that
render some of your services for some of
these
authentic hats i do steve buscemi i do
them for boardwalk
this was the king of tonga the king of
tonga
really yeah you make his hat
here's where we come in okay that's what
i'm talking about right here
i smell importance so remember how we
had those
those raw bodies yeah and now we got
this so this is how the hat looks
after it's done oh it starts off like
that you wet your hands
shape it steam it rope it yeah and it
comes out like this
man so it's like there's four strands of
this that's a lot
that's a process they steam it they add
sulfur to soften it to bleach it
and then they take their fingers and
they spill it like that
and it starts from here orlando you're
sure this
is [ __ ] amazing what's your most
expensive hat you think you saw 25
25 000. this man worked on it for one
year
wow twenty five thousand dollars for one
hat i gotta show it
you have it i have a few
[ __ ] let's do that show me that
these hats cost twenty five thousand
dollars you don't have an alarm or
something
they don't hear the adt anybody that
comes in here
knows not to [ __ ] with our land that's
right
chop them
you see the hat swag
[Music]
hey man i really appreciate you letting
me invade your store
you know when you get to heaven yeah and
you get there's
there's saint peter they say he does two
things
he hands you the keys to the gate okay
he hands your pen in my hand
that was deep that bore orlando
really got them plug numbers 25 racks
for a hat takes a year to make starts
with four strands
very interesting process but do you
think it's worth it
leave a comment subscribe to the gq
channel
for more most expensive [ __ ]